hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo lo
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el flujo migratorio hacia eeuu sigue en
aumento en 2021 del éxodo hacia el norte
creció en parte tras la llegada de joe
biden a la presidencia pero otros
factores como la persecución y la crisis
económica causada por la pandemia
llevaron a muchos a emigrar las
autoridades fronterizas en eeuu reportan
una alta llegada de venezolanos sólo en
mayo fueron interceptados siete mil 484
migrantes de esa nacionalidad en la
frontera con mexico la cifra más alta en
14 años los datos revelan que desde
enero más de 17 mil 300 venezolanos
cruzaron ilegalmente lo que llama la
atención es que se trata de
profesionales que habían migrado hacia
otros países de latinoamérica pero que
tuvieron que volver al camino por cuenta
del cob y 19 veamos más en el siguiente
informe
huyendo de venezuela o yendo a venezuela
ahora están lejos de su país y cruzan el
río grande para llegar a suelo
estadounidense
un viaje que finalmente los lleva al
otro lado de la frontera donde son
interceptados por la patrulla fronteriza
y detenidos por algunas horas
si quieres mover tu cámara puedes ver
algunas personas cruzando por allí
quiero decir nos ven aquí en la frontera
y no tienen ningún temor de nosotros
están llegando y luego se rinden vienen
a darse por vencidos che qué bó y hemos
visto un aumento en esta área de
ciudadanos haitianos y venezolanos
nations la pandemia agudizó el éxodo
hacia eeuu por lo que las familias
completas llegan a esta zona
solamente dios sabe por todo lo que
hemos aprendido santo
y no quiero más
liz es una ingeniera de petróleos de 27
años que no encontró trabajo en
venezuela por su oposición al gobierno
emigró a chile y trabajó en una empresa
de tecnología pero la pandemia la obligó
a reubicarse nuevamente pues una vida
mejor
en este albergue transitorio esperan
poder seguir su camino de tenis fueron
al extremo de kate los venezolanos son
extremadamente educados ayer tuvimos
médicos e ingenieros de petróleos y
hasta es wow tiene profesores
universitarios han pasado por nuestra
organización recientemente estas
personas están preparados
financieramente dispar
fanny away el pasado mes de marzo el
gobierno demócrata le otorgó el estatus
de protección temporal a unos 320 mil
venezolanos un alivio que les permite
trabajar legalmente y los protege de la
deportación
es común que en ese viaje hacia eeuu se
encuentren migrantes procedentes en su
mayoría de los países del llamado
triángulo norte honduras el salvador y
guatemala
por eso el éxodo de tal número de
venezolanos es algo que cambia en el
flujo migratorio pero hay también otro
grupo de personas que buscan refugio en
eeuu tras los hechos contra opositores
en nicaragua y la proximidad de las
elecciones algunos nicaragüenses
decidieron emigrar
la crisis política económica y de
derechos humanos en nicaragua agudiza la
migración de sus ciudadanos hacia eeuu
el éxodo y regular aumentó en un
seiscientos setenta por ciento de enero
a mayo mientras el gobierno de daniel
ortega acordar a la oposición cientos
prefieren salir del país antes de las
presidenciales de noviembre me viene por
eso más que todo porque llegan a hacer
elección y se va a poner feo eso ya
entre poquito ya despedido octubre ya
caen las elecciones
no es que todos corremos peligro de ahí
si solo su gente la que no corre peligro
la del gobierno y es que temen volver a
vivir lo ocurrido en 2018 cuando se
desataron protestas masivas contra la
administración sandinista y se
cometieron un sinnúmero de violaciones a
los derechos humanos en el 2018 puedes
sufrir mucho porque también ahí me
reventaron la cabeza tengo cicatrices en
la espalda puñaladas también operaron y
todo pues pero
porque todo pues no la sufre como
nicaragüense a veces pues si no está del
lado gobierno uno
levav a este grupo de nicaragüenses está
varado en mexico la guardia nacional
desplegada por el gobierno mexicano para
detener el viaje de los migrantes hacia
el norte bloquea el paso no está
predicando mucho por eso hay mucha gente
mutilada en el tren le pase el tren
mucho golpeado porque uno lo agarra
corriendo la única manera ya corriendo
50-60 kilómetros por hora y algo
peligrosísimo y le digo el presidente de
mexico que por favor quite todo todo
operativo porque nosotros simplemente
son muy inmigrantes
vamos con rumbo al norte a eeuu según la
agencia de la onu para los refugiados
unos 108 mil nicaragüenses abandonaron
el país desde 2018 en busca de
protección
la inestabilidad política en los países
de américa latina y las consecuencias
económicas de la pandemia preocupan
especialmente a eeuu que teme una crisis
cerca de casa y por ende el aumento de
la migración hacia el país el gobierno
de joe biden reitera que no es momento
para emigrar y el dato de migración de
la semana un millón 119 mil 204
inmigrantes sin documentos fueron
detenidos por la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza de eeuu en lo
corrido del último año fiscal es decir
desde octubre de 2020 los adultos que
viajan solos lideran la lista de
detenciones
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]